what do you think about like
youtube being this destination for
stunts and these i mean you look at like
the elk boys you look at all these
groups of people who probably grew up
watching you guys right and then have
gone on to have tons of success doing it
are are you looking at this going wow we
inspired a generation or are you looking
at like they're jacking our [ __ ]
is it love is it either admiration is it
neither and what a fascinating dynamic
man i um
uh
i i had
like the run
with
jackass up until the third movie which
came out in 2010 and i was i was newly
sober in in 2010 i was starting with the
comedy in 2010 and um
the comedy was in its infancy i had no
idea if it was going to work but i was
just giving it hell and trying my best
and uh i was very unsure about that
come 2013
the one gig i had on tv i got fired from
and
knoxville was making the bad grandpa
movie
you know
under the jackass name jackass presents
and it was like wait a second dude
they're making a jackass movie
without us you know like we got
timberlaked
now i'm the
four
you know yeah i'm [ __ ] tito yeah you
know like
dude and i was i had the darkest [ __ ]
up year
like uh i was you know i was really in a
you know the [ __ ] funk and um
at one point in that year
uh some guy
a manager called me into a meeting to
talk about managing me and this guy 2013
who were talking a decade ago and he
says dude it's all about the digital
space you got to have a youtube channel
you got to have a podcast you got to be
cranking on social media that's where
it's at
and and i was like
listening to this and i thought okay i'm
hearing what he's saying but it sounds
like he's describing me doing a bunch of
work to create all this great content
by myself
and he's not describing he does [ __ ]
and the proposal is that he gets 10 of
everything that i do
and on top of that i felt like
dude like i've been in like number one
box office movies like i'm like you know
like it felt like such a depressing
demotion to be like now
i'm uploading youtube videos you know
like yeah and and um
the fact was that i was just in such a
[ __ ] dark depressed spot
um
that i just to keep my sanity i just
[ __ ] and my other buddy was like dude
i'm killing it in youtube like [ __ ]
you know he taught me how to edit yeah
and now i've no longer needed any
[ __ ] permission from any [ __ ]
corporate [ __ ] to allow me to do
something now just do whatever the [ __ ]
so back then that was 2013 when i
launched my youtube channel
and that was where like i didn't even
i did not think that there was any like
real money in what i was doing i thought
it was kind of embarrassing but i was
just doing it to keep myself sane yeah
and then over the years since then
we've seen the emergence of the logan
paul's
the [ __ ] nilk boys i just watched a
video
uh
the title of it was something like the
influencer bubble is gonna pop you know
and it was like
it said that these [ __ ] youtube
people
are now
making as much or more than bona fide
[ __ ]
a-list stars yeah more and foreign and
like top athletes way more and top
athletes is is closed yeah i don't think
but but as far as like bona fide movie
stars like the years of the 20 million
dollar movie started done like the i
mean maybe tom cruise for like a top gun
if he's getting points in the movie that
kind of stuff but like nobody's paying
will smith 20 million for a movie
anymore they're just not bringing in the
money right so those numbers going way
down and the youtubers i mean you look
at like jake you look at logan look at
what they're bringing in obviously they
have other endeavors but like they're
making big [ __ ] money youtube is
television now yeah back in the day when
we grew up and we were watching jackass
even before that you just turned on the
tv and whatever came on you kind of
watched that's youtube
they're still the pay channels you know
the hbo's and the streaming networks the
netflix et cetera those things still
exist just like they existed back then
we have very specific content that
you'll tune in for but in terms of just
popping on the tv and leaving something
like that's youtube tv is [ __ ] done
and i don't know for me i just want to
be where the people are and i think that
that's what you realize very early
i'm so [ __ ] thankful yeah that uh
doesn't feel better to have your destiny
in your own hands they're 100 it's like
i i took control of my own [ __ ]
and uh
and did that that in 2013 man i was in
that [ __ ] [ __ ] up funk and at the time
the biggest people in the the prank
space on youtube were roman atwood and
this guy is vitaly and i collaborated
with both of them
double upload where i did a thing on
their channel they drove all their
traffic to my channel
like it was like
it was a quadruple [ __ ] collab yeah
in every direction
and uh
and and the day that i launched my
youtube channel i went from zero
subscribers to like way over a hundred
thousand wow yeah and in
like within like
two or three days
my lawyer was calling up saying that
like the big agencies wanted to get you
in for meetings of course you know like
i had no agent and um
you know if you build it they will come
yeah as simple as that
yeah i
again have no [ __ ] agent like but you
don't need it now yeah i don't know you
do everything you want to do you create
the things you want to create right if
people want to buy in they buy in if
they don't you just do it for the people
who already love you and they want to
see what you got to do it's very simple
it's the best way to create right you
just have to i don't know if you
struggle with this some people struggle
with this idea especially if they're
older like they validate themselves
through like the network names and the
brand names so they're like well if i'm
not in a movie then i'm not doing
something when they don't realize that
like the kids that watch you right they
never saw you on tv bro right they only
know youtube youtube is tv to them sure
matter of fact if you're like yeah i
have this movie jackass out there like
damn who gives a [ __ ] i just these kids
are going to zoom classes they don't go
out to the movie theater anymore it's a
new generation
as an example
a dear friend of mine
has a stepson
who just graduated from this
like ultra elite
high school
which kanye west's kids go to he raps
about their high school
maybe they're not in high school but the
same school like uh
canyon exactly yeah sierra canyon
lebron's kids lebron's kids
this [ __ ]
this kid
is on lebron's instagram page
and like
he's completely unfazed by that but when
he found out that i was collaborating
with steve will do it and the elk boys
the kids [ __ ] head
his head exploded they're like dude you
used to be like a [ __ ]
run-of-the-mill [ __ ] whatever
and now because of your affiliation with
the nilk boys you are the coolest
[ __ ] kid in my entire house because
the cool thing about now is that the
creators are the validators back in the
day it was like you had to be on mtv you
had to be on hbo and to be one of these
channels now you could be on the
channels but if it's not hot it means
nothing you can have a show on netflix
but if nobody's watching it
nobody gives a [ __ ] right like there are
people who have nbc sitcoms right now
that you and i don't know are even on
the air yeah that didn't happen back in
the day but if you do something with elk
boys everybody's going oh [ __ ] he's
popping i i will absolutely agree with
you on the network television but i'm
going to push back on the netflix piece
because with the with the netflix number
one like there's no such thing as a flop
because they don't reveal their numbers
and number two like the like when you
had your netflix budget your multi-part
special come out that changed your life
right not even close not even close did
less
wow i did it for boomers i did it
because boomers still need to see the
validation that's some wind in my sails
bro i'm being serious like i did it for
people to be honest like you
they go you see you see me have a
netflix special next to my name you're
like oh he's legit how do you explain
bert kreischer bert is is a
bert will tell you this studio's face
burt is a marketing genius one
has an amazing live show too
but three is a viral sensation it is
youtube that blew him up he had a
showtime special that he ripped off if
you look at anybody selling tickets
right now none of them are doing it
because of netflix wow you look at the
people really no i mean this none of
them are doing because of netflix
nothing to do because of hbo another one
doing because of tv there's a lot of
people who have those specials but
they're not doing it the the the people
who are selling tickets right now are on
youtube they're releasing specials on
youtube they have podcasts on youtube
they're able to build in that space and
the beautiful thing about you having
your own youtube is every time you do
something big it drives people back to
your content for sure they're people
that you're gonna watch on this thing
and they're gonna be like oh i didn't
even know who to podcast boom spike
we haven't mentioned my podcast
i don't have a podcast it's insane but
listen the beautiful thing about youtube
is you don't need to mention [ __ ]
youtube youtube mentions it just
watching it and all of a sudden right
here it's like yo you might like this
right and you go you will say to youtube
youtube i don't like that and then the
next day it goes i think you're gonna
like this
i don't like that and then three days
later it keeps recommending it you're
like fine
[Applause]
[Music]
you